(audience applause)
- It means so much to me.
(indistinct)
- All right, we're back
with DIY with Lauren Mack,
and she's showing us how
to make our own inexpensive
Japandi inspired console table.
All right, so now as one
last step, we're gonna...
- Yes.
- Literally, I'm supposed to...
- Well, while you do that, you go ahead.
You get the caulk, or the glue on there.
This is industrial strength glue.
But while you guys are looking
at, while she's doing that,
I want you to see this. This
is the finished product.
This is what it looks like
when it's all said and done.
We sanded the edges after
we use that joint compound.
(audience applause)
And this is the real trick, Luiz.
At this point, you can
paint this any color
so that it customizes to your decor.
You can do black, you could do white.
You know, this, these
neutral shapes are really...
Oh, excuse me, the neutral colors
is really a part of Japandi design.
It's very minimalism.
Lots of neutrals and bright neutrals.
Okay?
- Do you see the expression on my face?
- Yes, girl.
You are into this.
- But it's like, this is what
happens when I DIY or cook.
I look incredibly uptight.
- Yes. Yes, yes.
- All right.
- You gotta get into it. You gotta be,
you gotta be committed.
- I'm not like, ah ha-ha-ha-ha.
I'm like (grunt).
(laughing)
- I know. I do a lot of DIY videos
and I always look at my
own footage and I'm like,
"Why was I making that face?"
(audience laughs)
- [Drew] How is that?
- Yes!
That is it, girl.
Yes!
(audience applause)
- [Drew] Oh, yeah.
- [Lauren] Boom!
Okay.
And then ontop a wood.
How beautiful is that? All right?
(audience applause continues)
- [Drew] We did it.
- [Lauren] You did it.
You did it.
- [Drew] Thank you.
Oh, thank you, Lauren.
- You did it.
- This is gorgeous.
- Thank you
- Luiz, would something
like this suit your needs?
- Absolutely. It looks amazing.
It looks very easy to do.
So, can't wait.
- [Drew] Well, it's all
yours if you want it.
And if not, we'll get you a gift card
for something in the Japandi
style that suits your needs.
- Amazing. Thank you.
(audience applause)
Thank you.
- [Drew] All right.
But you gotta start
that decorating journey.
I love this.
- [Lauren] You do?
- Oh, yeah.
- You can have this one,
and Luiz can have that one.
- Oh, by the way... That,
there's two of them.
We both get one.
- There's two.
- [Luiz] Amazing.
(audience applause)
- Perfect.
You get a console table,
and you get a console table.
Thank you, Lauren.
Thank you so much.
- [Lauren] Thank you.
- Will you please come back?
- Yes.
- [Drew] Teach us
how to do more stuff.
- We're gonna get you DIY-ing
I want you to, I want you
to get in here and do your,
do more of these for your own self.